hallo clixoom hallo uwu lena also mein
name ist daniel und ich habe eine frage
an euch beziehungsweise dich hättest du
bzw ihr jemals erwartet dass sie so
schnell
er bringt in deutschland werden ja sie
werden auf keinen fall damit gerechnet
dass wir so schnell berühmt werden und
wir wollen uns auch noch nicht selbst
berühmt nennen uns freut das natürlich
dass der song allen leuten so gut
gefällt
kommt die wirtschaft aus münster weil
wir meinten view steht das mag ihm steht
das nicht und das wird sich auch fragen
und das war's auch schon ja wir sind
tatsächlich bis auf eine ausnahme
unseren sänger der nahe bamberg aus der
region bamberg kommt sind wir alle
tatsächlich münsteraner und entgegen
allen verschwörungstheorien die uns als
von irgendwoher zusammen gecastet
darstellen stimmt das wirklich